bacon you like bacon cheddar cheese yeah
hey guys we are epic high long time no
see buzzfeed i am
tableau of epic i uh produce and i rap
the king of horror core mithra right
here do you guys know
what we're going to do today do you know
what a what bff is
pot
[Laughter]
okay man b-u-t right yeah okay
[Music]
best friend forever
[Laughter]
try to guess how many things we know
about each other the first one is
full birthdays i know yours i know yours
yours is two days after my wife's
birthday
so there's no way legally that i can
forget it
because i would die yes
july 22nd instagram leave comments
favorite singer band
mike tukas really doesn't like music
honestly
you pretend to like certain singers and
bands to look
cool when it was cool to love radiohead
he
pretended to like radiohead and then i
asked him one day
to name one song and he couldn't
remember that
okay that was the name of the album
what is it imagine the red ones
yeah right name three songs by imagine
dragons three songs
imagine never
that's my daughter's favorite that's
haru's favorite she literally listens to
the same song
a thousand times in a row it's crazy
celebrity crush
name three songs by billy joel
names of their parents so your name is
mithra jin
so maybe their name is like
like asap rocky asap his name is mithra
jin
dad's name is like mithra shin who's
i saw you buy um 18 bottles
[Laughter]
i actually quit drinking for a reason
that i
wish i could go live i don't want to
discuss i quit drinking for my health
but i
i'm pretty sure i'm gonna drink today
favorite drunk food
you don't know anything about me shut up
it's really good though
we all love chicken favorite song off
our new album one two three at the same
time i think i know what you're gonna
say i also know
what you're going to say should i tell
you so that you say it one two
three
favorite music genre mithra's favorite
music show
hardcore hardcore hip-hop do you guys
know what hardcore is it's um
hardcore mixed with horror mithra used
to be in a hardcore
uh group if you've never seen our first
times video
go and check that out because that's how
he used to rap
no i don't like rock i love rocks no
it's not my favorite
it's actually classical music
[Laughter]
you said that you spat on the back of my
head your favorite genre jazz
k-pop dance music no no no you you said
you said big bang's a fantastic baby is
the greatest song ever made in the
history of music
is like your favorite kind of style of
music
favorite pizza topping chose cheese
straight cheese
bacon you like bacon cheddar cheese yeah
i like hawaiian pizza i hate yo why do
people
hate people who like hawaiian pizzas
do you hate people who like hawaiian
pizzas
i've never understood anything about you
favorite song they ever wrote your
favorite song you ever wrote
is probably born hater no
born hater made you the most money
daughter
[Music]
love love love rosario yes
best friends
my favorite song is actually based on a
true story from this album i love
that it's a hip-hop song with no drums
originally it had drums that two cuts
did
and then i went in there i selected
the drums and then i pressed delete
best friend their biggest fear
oh i know god no
i know your biggest fear your wife
correct correct life
correct
your mom why do you keep talking about
my family dude
their hidden talent yeah this guy
the korean gambit so on our tick tock
account we're like yo do you have any
skills and
mithra's like i don't know maybe i can
throw a card and then he did it and he
turned off the light with it just one
try
amazing korean gambling two cuts uh
[Music]
rula three four three four wonder girls
tell me
no so hot oh so hot about best friend
epic so hot is the best remix of that
song
best cover ever biggest pet peeve
mithra i think is like one
to cut moving no
working though trying hard
rapping
[Applause]
hey
our new album epic high is here part one
is
out if you haven't heard the songs then
like what are you doing
go and check that out thank you
[Music]
you